treasury secretary janet yellen is
warning of dire downright catastrophic
consequences if congress does not raise
the nation's debt limit yellen told a
senate hearing yesterday that the
government could run out of money to pay
its bills by october 18th less than
three weeks from right now
that would create the first federal
default in american history cbs news
business analyst jill schlesinger is
with us now this all sounds very bad
yeah
also technical and a little confusing so
what's going to happen if the debt
ceiling is not increased well what has
to happen right now is the treasury has
to make a series of plans and there are
not a lot of good choices so the first
would be shuddering national monuments
museums and that would be one easy thing
to do quickly not great if you're
planning your vacation the next would be
furloughing employees this could affect
500 000 government employees maybe
another million on top who would work
without pay temporarily and then finally
this would mean potentially delaying
social security checks going out
infecting really i'm sorry impacting so
many older americans the deaf com one
the real serious one is we get to that
october 18th date and the u.s can't pay
the interest on some of its bonds
that's the real scary situation that
exists in the future now janet yellen
compared it to paying off a credit card
what what does she mean by that well
imagine if you and i decided we're you
know we're married and we say okay let's
go buy a flat screen tv we agree to it
we know we're going to have to pay this
back we put it on a credit card but we
got to pay the credit card company yeah
yellen is saying congress has already
voted on a series of steps about funding
and these have been enacted so that
could be the 2017 tax cuts that can be
the emergency measures through covet
it's funding social security and
medicare and military we've already
agreed to that lifting the debt ceiling
simply says we are paying the bill on
the obligation we already agreed to
that's why she made that concern so
politically there's this they're tied
together these two big bills
infrastructure and social infrastructure
but in reality the debt ceiling has
nothing to do with those it's got to do
with past bills that's exactly right and
past commitments that congress both
sides of congress have already made
right now um
stocks suffered the worst dip since
march now with the debt ceiling looming
um is there more volatility to come in
the market you betcha and i think this
would be a real hold on to your seats on
this one because if we go back a decade
the last time we came close to hitting
the debt ceiling that is when stocks
fell by 14
in four weeks gang that would be like 4
800 dow points over the ensuing month so
there are going to be bumps remember as
stocks go down there's a lot of urge to
do something we try not to do something
because what we did also see 10 years
ago is when we got out of that situation
stocks resumed their upward assessment
opportunity in there too oh look at this
one he's always looking opportunity
opportunity
jill's middle name is
be cool just sit relax it's gonna be
okay i like that as my middle name
cool schlesinger i like that hard to do
that though when you hear words like
dire and catastrophic good to have you
at the table sorting it all out for us
thank you